welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about how there are
infinite versions of you in infinite
universes and how all those infinite
versions still lie awake at night
thinking about that embarrassing time in
the third grade when you call it
infinite versions of your teacher mal
because it happened and people laughed
and laughed wouldn't stop laughing
uh my name is mt and i'm here today with
the wonderful amazing and super smart
hilarious marina masters what's going on
marina hey i think we all have that
memory but we all do it because like we
are always around our teachers like five
days a week and like they're usually
women and they're usually very kind so
just like hey mom it just slips out and
then you have to
go comatose right and then you know a
decade of therapy which is what i had to
do but yes hit me with that big question
marina let's get into it okay mt i'm
confused between the marvel movies and
the streaming series we've had a lot of
terms and concepts thrown our way
specifically related to things that make
up realities right so like dimensions
universes timelines everything like that
so we figured it was time to address
this big question in the mcu what is the
difference between timelines universes
realities realms dimensions and planes
wow uh planes trains and uh automobiles
geez i feel like i have to have a degree
in like quantum physics to know
the mcu multiverse because good god it's
very it's a lot but you're exactly right
there are a lot of ways the mcu has come
to explain reality in terms that relate
to time and space so let's go through
the major examples of each and see if we
can get some definitions in place that
makes sense if we can i don't know if
that's possible we can we can do it we
can do it we got to believe in ourselves
so let's begin by defining the timeline
since that is the term at the top of
everyone's mind at the end of loki so in
the show we saw how the tva worked at
the behest of he who remains aka
jonathan mages to maintain a secret
timeline and they would prune any
variants that they saw as a threat to
the sacred timeline in an effort to
prevent any branch timelines from
forming as you know as you should as
anyone should because you know it's got
to keep a a nice tiny timeline with you
i like to think he he who remains that's
a hedge cutter hey your hedge cutter's
like
yeah yeah and everyone else was like
dinkleberg dinkleberg anyway the head
writer for loki michael waldron very
great guy got to talk to him very just
really cool chill dude recently did an
interview with screen crush where he
explained just how he and his team
envisioned how time and timelines worked
because thank you michael aldrin he's
just a nice man who does nice things
like that he described time as always
happening and that there are infinite
instances of time always occurring at
once so if you recall in the final
episode of loki we see the citadel at
the end of time surrounded by a big
white ring around the castle and it's
not a straight line but an infinite loop
i'm going to explain what he means by
basically paraphrasing the example he
gave in the interview so marina you and
i right now are doing big questions are
we not yes or no yes yes that's right
right now in the present that is what we
are doing but there is also an instance
of us having this conversation 10
seconds ago but there's also an instance
of us talking 10 seconds from now
because that is how time works it's
pretty crazy right if we don't explode
in like the next nine seconds so
you have these three instances and they
each could be their own separate
timelines for the most part they're all
the same and they all follow the same
trajectory but each instance could have
its own tiny fluctuation so in this
conversation five times out of ten i
would say welcome to big question marina
and then four times out of ten i might
say i'm here on big question with my
favorite guest marina but in one of
those instances out of ten i might say i
don't want to do big question with
maureen anymore i hate marina she's the
worst person that ever lived that is of
obviously evil empty not the first time
that's happened so that would really
deviate from the normal path this big
question would take and you would
probably kill me for being such a jerk
because you know rightfully so and thus
a branch timeline would be formed from
that really dramatic event yeah so when
we talk about the sacred timeline it was
actually a bunch of timelines bundled
together like similar to like a fiber
optic chord you know
verizon cable uh installer people yeah
that's a big chunk of our audience
eighty percent uh like finally i get the
call out i deserve so similar to a fiber
optic chord which looks like just one
chord but if you were to cut it in half
you would see it's actually made up of
many tiny strands of wire right bundled
together so the tva was tasked with
monitoring the tapered timeline so it
maintained a condition where he who
remains was in charge in the citadel at
the end of time and any variants that
would cause a branch timeline were
pruned thus preserving the sacred
timeline and they kept this bundle of
timelines all moving in the same
direction to provide the desired outcome
so let us discuss the tva and pruning
for just one moment will you let me do
that will you let me do that marina
sir
permission granted okay so when a
variant did something that contradicted
with the plan for the secret timeline
the variant would be pruned by stopping
the variant in its deviations before
their timeline crossed that red line
threshold their branch timeline would
not grow enough to establish a new
reality so when the tva would prune a
variant it allowed the main timeline to
merge back in with the standard timeline
remember those reset charges didn't blow
up everything they just removed the
elements they had deviated from the
secret timeline oh
that actually makes more sense because i
mean not that i'm not a genius i'm not
but like watching it it's like okay yeah
they reset that how does that make it
how does that force it not to make a
branch but it's the just the parts that
are deviating so
it just bundles back into itself or it
doesn't have enough of a difference to
create its own timeline i guess and also
you are a genius to give yourself a
little bit more credit okay we all
geniuses here all right that's why we
get paid the big bucks yeah yeah yeah i
am definitely getting paid at least one
big i'm uh living out of a
a box with a can of a chef boy or d yeah
this is a cardboard house
these are cardboard walls so in the
final episode of loki we saw how the
sacred timeline began to branch and
split into different multiverses if you
missed it i don't know what you were
doing you were probably not watching
loki you are probably doing disney plus
and thrust don't do it pay attention to
the mcu anyway the bundle of timelines
had come undone and now the branch
timelines were allowed to grow no longer
being pruned by the time variants
authority because remember this happens
before he who remains is killed by
sylvie so it must be something that was
allowed to happen so this means the mcu
is now full of way more branch timelines
than ever before it's gonna be mad it's
gonna be madness among the verse of
madness there you go segway yes
you
let's talk universes in reality so how
do timelines compare to universes so in
the beginning of the final episode of
loki when we hear the cacophony of
voices we zoom out from our solar system
and through our galaxy to see our entire
universe contained within a black hole
and it's right next to another black
hole that we then zoom into and these
two black holes show us an example of
two universes later in that same episode
he who remains shows us how a kang
variant discovered universes stacked on
top of his own like
like a krabby patty you know what i'm
saying that's right like that's that's
the original stack the krabby patty
patty on a bun with lettuce cheese
onions tomatoes ketchup mustard pickles
and top bun together in that order and
then if you have a pog then you can flip
it and you get whichever universe is
turned over exactly exactly do you know
what pogs are am i the only one who's
that old so these looked very similar to
the black hole universes we saw at the
beginning of the episode universe has a
kang making the same discovery so he
also says the peace between realities
erupted like a volcano so this shows us
that the universes and realities are
similar concepts in the marvel cinematic
universe okay
so within each universal reality you
have a bundle of infinite timelines
capable of creating their own variants
and branch timelines okay it's kind of
weird no no that makes that actually
makes
sense now thank you thank you like no
one thinks i make sense but at least
marina does you know
so to use loki as an example we have our
loki from one universal reality sylvie
from another universe alligator loki
from another universe a better universe
than ours definitely classic loki kid
loki et cetera et cetera and all the
loki's we saw on the show were variants
of a loki from their own universe or
reality plus even though these variants
were pruned their unpruned counterparts
that they are variants of still go on
existing on a different timeline so that
means while we saw alligator loki in the
void there was still an alligator loki
in its own timeline within a universe
that didn't eat the wrong neighbor's cat
and cause a nexus event my head hurts
i'm going to have a stroke
interior crocodile alligator so let's
dive into what if because within the
recent premiere of the what if series we
now need to figure out where these
episodes fit so are they branch
timelines or are they their own
universal loops of times because at the
beginning of the first episode the
watcher says a single choice can branch
out into infinite realities creating
alternate worlds from the ones that you
know so it would appear that the what if
episodes are those branched timelines
formed when a variant makes a drastic
change from what would normally happen
so if you think back to our previous
example of marina and i having the ten
instances of our conversation the
what-if episodes are like the one out of
ten choice that greatly deviates from
the norm and the different choice is so
drastic it creates its own branch
reality similar to one of those branches
that we saw represented when the sacred
timeline started to split into those
different strands now let us figure out
how dimensions in realms fit into all of
this weird company of
okay so we have had different examples
of both dimensions and realms of the mcu
before everything we thought we knew got
smashed into smithereens in loki because
the thor film introduced the concept of
the nine realms in these places like
midgard yottenheim asgard et cetera
these all appear to be real physical
places that exist in different galaxies
within the universe because as we see in
you know guardians 2 rocket and yondu
and all them were just bumping across
the universe and we see them swoop past
the rock people the cronins from the
four movies so like you're able to
travel if you just had a ship you could
just travel to each other
so realms are just kind of like
continents yeah basically like sort of
like regions really far away yeah space
yeah they're space continents that's
actually a really good way to think
about it yeah the realms are just
continents that's really good space
continent who says you're not a genius
marina not me anymore
but then we have the quantum realm and
this is a little bit crazier than the
nine realms because we know to access
the quantum realm we have to shrink down
to a subatomic level because that's what
quantum means quantum deals with the
subatomic particles that just don't make
sense and time also operates very
differently in the quantum realm as do
many other things and it's through the
quantum realm that tony is able to
unlock the secrets of time travel so
really the quantum realm operates more
like a dimension or like sort of like a
a dimension that acts as a pathway and
the dimensions of the mcu appear to
exist between universes for example when
describing the dark dimension where de
mamu resides wang says that the dark
dimension exists beyond time and he also
says that therma wants to invade every
universe so that would also support the
idea that the dark dimension exists
outside of any one universe
and there are other dimensions mentioned
in the mcu as well such as the mirror
dimension and the astral dimension so
far they have only been accessed by
practitioners of the mystic arts but
that just stands to support the idea
that dimensions exist in between
universes they're less physical
locations they're just you know just
right between those universes you know
you know
because they're all around us and they
don't they like operate differently and
so what if it's like you're looking at a
picture and it's like you put a green
like filter on it and it's like taking
up the same space
it exists in the same space but it's
like
functioning differently it's like a
different yeah like it's occupying the
same space like there's another marina
right here but she she doesn't talk like
me and she's she like is separate she
like her limbs are separate from her
body and it's like she's a total she's a
fish or something it's like totally
weird she's like layered on but it's lit
but it's still right here yeah it's just
like yeah i see i know i know exactly
what you're saying it's just a really
weird concept yeah
but okay but like if there are any
physicists like i don't know why a
physicist would listen to this but if
there are any they're probably just like
screaming like marina is so stupid
you're stupid your best try was so bad
no i feel like physicists are learning
from us i think that we're actually
making the laws of physics and you're
welcome to publish this in your next
paper dimensions were like green filters
that you
put in a picture
so one more thing the guardians of the
galaxy were hired to stop an abolish
from eating the anti-lack batteries of
the sovereign the abilis is described as
an interdimensional being therefore it
has the ability to pass from a dimension
into our universe feeding on whatever
power source it is drawn through and it
is possible that the abolis could access
multiple universes not just ours so it
could eat draxes in every universe
because draxes are quite delicious
uh that sounds pretty uh
that to cut that out i don't want that
on the internet why um no but what's
funny is that in what if there are
actually these tentacled monsters that
captain carter fights at the end of
episode one yeah so i believe that there
is a link between the abolis from
guardians 2 and these technical
creatures
seem to be both interdimensional
travelers on the interdimensional
highway yeah the interdimensional rivers
yeah planes now let's talk about planes
my favorite disney pixar franchise why
do they make that franchise i don't know
it's a really hot take i know of the
plane community is going to be like yo
what the man
to so the best example of a plane is the
astral plane that we see in black
panther of course yeah so while the
rules of the ancestral plane it may be
bound by wakandan mysticism it appears
to function very much like an astral
dimension similar to the one that we saw
doctor strange in in doctor strange the
astral dimension is a place where the
soul can exist separate from the body so
in this case the ancestral plane could
be a dimension within our universe
rather than a dimension that exists
between universes so we don't see former
black panthers from other universes in
the ancestral plane when we see it in
black panther just the ones from our
universe so it's just localized to our
universe there we've discussed realities
already but what about pocket reality so
the best example of this would be the
hex created by darla witch in okay
very big pocket reality there and this
is a reality that exists within the
larger marvel universe reality and as we
saw the hex can affect things outside of
its borders and it was able to make the
cops not even realize that the town of
west view was right there like there's
literally a sign right there and they're
like what there's on the east view
west what east high of east high nights
that's what we do a high school musical
bet on it bet on it that's a bop that's
a pop right there
okay i'm not gonna say again all right
sorry anyway so pocket realities can
exist within larger realities and not be
their own separate universes in
conclusion so we've covered a lot of
terms and concepts here my brain is uh
fried
i'm so sorry my brain but i think that
we've done a good job of putting some
definitions in place on the granite
scale you have universes and or
realities and within each universal
reality you have infinite timelines and
these timelines you create branches and
these branches can intersect and that's
basically everything so but also in
between those universes you have
dimensions and within each universe you
can have realms planes or dimensions and
pocket realities
so hopefully that all helps you wrap
your hand around the ever-growing
craziness of the mcu but well at least
until spider-man no way home and doctor
straight to the moment madness comes
along that makes things even more
confusing because why would they make it
easy for us why why why why why why
why i mean that would mean that they
they loved us or something what
they ask you how you are you just have
to say that you're fine when you're not
really fine so
that is it for our first question but
before we continue on with the video you
should check out our most recent
addition to our latest obsession line of
church inspired by the suicide squad a
magnificent movie you should see it now
we've got a limited supply of those so
be sure to grab each one before the tiny
bomb inside your brain explodes
we've also got a really cool king shark
jaws inspired shirt that is subtle in
the same way our recent loki gator polo
shirt was and it's a great way to
support the channel and all the awesome
content that we produce so please head
on over at newrocksourcemerch.com
and we love you and before we dive into
our bite size questions next some words
from the folks that help bring big
question to you folks like coinbase so
um let me ask you a question do you
identify as crypto curious because if
you've ever
oh
[Laughter]
i'll never damn
[Music]
well let me tell you if you've ever been
curious if you've ever thought about
entering the world of cryptocurrency but
felt a little overwhelmed which is
totally reasonable coinbase makes
learning to buy and sell really simple
coinbase offers a trusted and
easy-to-use platform to buy sell and
spend cryptocurrency they support the
most popular digital currencies on the
market and make them accessible to
everyone even me
they offer portfolio management and
protection learning resources and a
mobile app so you can trade securely and
monitor your crypto all in one place
millions of people in over 100 countries
trust coinbase with their digital assets
whether you're looking to diversify just
getting started or searching for a
better way to access crypto markets
start today with coinbase for a limited
time new users can get five dollars in
free bitcoin when you sign up today at
coinbase.com big questions sign up at
coinbase.com bigquestion for five bucks
and free bitcoin oh my god dollars this
uh guys those offers are a limited time
only so be sure to sign up today that's
coinbase.com big question excellent ad
read marina but thanks now it is time
for our bite size question and i have a
question for you marina are you ready
are you ready are you ready for this
marina can a spro
shapeshift into an animal and this is
from kingprawn spawn on twitter thank
you king broth kingprong spawn that's a
hard king crossing prawns
but that is actually a really good
question um and the answer is yes but
the more elaborative answer is that it
has been established in marvel comics
that scrolls can in fact shape-shift
into animals um the best example of this
are the infamous skrull cows okay
yes i do mean cow or like the utter kind
yep
so way back in fantastic four number two
from 1961
some skrulls came to earth as part of a
planned invasion okay and then the end
they're thwarted by the fantastic four
and they run back to scrollos however
three of the scrolls are left behind on
earth so reed richards in order to
safely lock them away hypnotizes them
into thinking they are cows which is
maybe the funnest thing i've ever heard
i'm a cow i'm a cow and
leaves him in a pasture he just leaves
them in a nice pasture to peacefully
graze away the remaining existence and
like there's really nice pastures along
the pch right and i hope it's in one of
those yeah it's like really like and
they have a sign that says watch for
falling cows because there's cows that
graze on the mountains but it's like
right by the cliff so sometimes the cows
fall down
they have to make signs for falling cows
literally have signs that say watch for
fallen cows road slippery when wet with
cow blood
jesus christ literally
and technically i guess one of those
cows that maybe has fallen down could
have been a skrull
it's true statistically according to my
calculations
she could happen oh my god
um but these scrolls maybe not because
they didn't remain as cows forever they
eventually break free right of their
bovine imprisonment um and attack they
attack the avengers but then they get
captured and turned back into cows again
again
a again
nothing new nothing changed same old
same old
bro how do you take the same terrible l
twice yeah like how are you gonna get
turned into a cow two times in your life
dude they they they lost and it stayed
out it did not turn into a lesson they
just
did the l twice
wow so the skrull cows would also play a
role in the creation of roll kill crew
in the mid 90s
one of the skrull cows was oh my god
this is so sad okay this is if you
thought that them being turned into cows
was like sad a little bit this is even
worse because one of the skrull cows was
butchered
and turned into a hamburger
[Applause]
yeah it was turned into a hamburger and
some of the people who ate the meat the
hamburger meat
got the scrolls adaptable dna code and
transfer they got the code transferred
into their bodies giving them
shape-shifting abilities as well as an
intense fear and hatred of the scrolls
but this condition was called
scrullavoria
and
that induced scrollophobia
naturally yes and that was and this
whole thing this whole concept which is
wild by the way was based on the very
real mad cow disease thing that happened
in the 90s at the in the beef industry
which is like a real thing so they were
just like what if we did this with
scroll stuff and you just like eat a
skrull hamburger and then you you go
nuts it's so wild it's so wild
i'm not loving this not loving this
story oh my god i know i'm so sorry but
okay but on a separate note okay and
then in infinity number one from 2013
we see actually a cat shift back into a
scroll so not only can squirrels turn
into cows but apparently it can be other
animals too because they did they were a
cat at one point um but we'll have to
wait and see if any squirrels wind up
turning into animals in the mcu or like
on your dinner plate as a burger if you
didn't already mistrust cats before yeah
yeah yeah first should be an alien yeah
and they could want to you know
take over your life and stab you
probably anyway okay so let's go to our
second bite size question this comes
from agabo shabbo on twitter a lot
easier to say
what are some of the more obscure force
powers in the star wars universe what a
great question um so over the years we
have seen a variety of force powers used
by both jedi and sith um we're all
pretty familiar with the common ones
like force lightning telekinesis and
mind tricks but actually if you start
digging into the legends canon you find
that there are some pretty interesting
force powers out there um so here's some
just like odd ones that um we came
across electric judgments okay so it's
basically the name of my band
it is a really good um band name so this
is basically the jedi's version of force
lightning um but usually the lightning
is only utilized by sith right however
jedi can use a less evil version of the
lightning um that they call electric
judgment opening up for coldplay oh my
god in 2022 everyone get vaccinated so
you can see electric judgment open up
for codeplay
oh my god um it's okay so the electric
judgment is usually
uh jettas can use it without tapping
into the dark side of the force um it's
usually a different color
and i guess maybe it's like less painful
um the sith think electric judgment is
like lame um and they're they might be
right on that one a little bit so you
said it was a less evil version of
lightning i've never heard that sentence
before in my life what is the less evil
version like oh i just got hit by
lightning but it was a little less evil
it's less evil than sith lightning you
know wow cause they're like they used to
play anything to like you know kill you
and stuff but but jedi or electric
judgment is more like what if you just
got warm for a minute
what if you just
i like to think that benjamin franklin
was out there with the kite and when it
got struck it was like whoa this
lightning is kind of good
this is i think this is good lightning
this is not evil lightning this is some
good lightning
i'm sure that's what happened another
kind of cute power is deadly sight very
cute uh this is actually a sith power so
it's not cute take back what i said
it's not cute
anyone within the sith's field of vision
will be burned alive
and disintegrated by the use of deadly
sight it's way cooler than just like
force choking it's kind of like
superman's tea vision but like bigger
and just like
all at once you know what i mean yeah
you're totally right this is not cute
it's sexy
sexy um okay so this one's really cool
this is called plant surge and it's a
light side horsepower plant surge does
just what it sounds like which is allows
the wielder to make plants grow really
fast and utilize them in battle um you
could wrap up your target in vines and
branches very like um nightmare on elm
street or like freddy krueger stuff like
that but this is an eco-friendly version
and it's a nice version so if you're a
jedi and you're gonna use this power
like don't be in the mojave desert
because there's like not that many
plants around but if you're in an
arboretum
you're all set okay so another one is
called cryokinesis um
if you're jedi you can do this and it
makes things colder that's it you can't
like manipulate ice or anything but you
could theoretically make your target
like die of hypothermia if you really
needed to um or just like experience the
temperature that exists in every movie
theater that i've been in
it's true it's very cold cool we also
have malaysia i think that's how you say
it m-a-l-a-c-i-a
if the internet wants to correct me go
ahead this will not be the first time uh
so this is a horsepower where you make
your target very dizzy and nauseated um
and it sounds kind of lame but have you
ever tried to fight someone when you
were throwing up you can't so it's
actually not that lame uh just like
imagine
if you're fighting darth vader and then
you made him football in his own helmet
like you'd basically win no one would
respect him ever again it sounds like a
dumb power but it's when you're when
your opponent wears a helmet it's pretty
clutch okay this is the last one this is
for scream ice cream you scream we all
scream for four screams for four scream
um
technically we did see this one in
revenge of the sith so when darth vader
woke up in his new half robot body and
found out padme was dead and he was like
no
um you may have forgotten that when he
did that cry of regret the droids and
equipment around him were damaged that's
because it wasn't just right he wasn't
just crying
just like normally that was a full-on
force frame um so the only the weirdest
thing about four screams though is that
they are involuntary so you can't like
you can't like intend to do it you just
have to like have a lot of emotions and
then it just happens so this is why jedi
don't have sex huh i think this is it i
think this is the reason we figured it
out it's the fourth scream honestly you
never know um there are like there are
more like weird force powers out there
but those are the coolest ones that we
could find um the most relevant ones so
if you know of a force power that we
missed come to the internet and yell at
me about it i i can also if you know how
to pronounce malaysia go for it
now it is time for my favorite segment
of the show the box of scraps sucked
so you better play that goofy box of
scraps like you did last week box of
scraps here is today's box of scraps
question if you can control one type of
animal like rat catcher from suicide
squad what animal would you like to
control here's here's here's my answer
and it's based on real science i would
control a chimpanzee or a gorilla
or all of them i guess or whatever if
it's if rat catcher gets to control all
rats then i'm gonna control all like
gorillas or chimpanzees okay and here's
why large apes
this is real okay they are ten times as
strong as a grown man so basically i
would have control of
literal
super strength
creatures
they can like
apes can rip your
limbs off like they can walk they can
walk up to you pick up your leg and rip
off your foot just like they can just
pop your bones apart they just feeling
like it you know because they just feel
like it and also because that stuff is
real also um chimp like highly
intelligent
apes and stuff they're capable of lying
to you so just for my i've always been
afraid of them because of that because
they can just like make stuff up
like you know they have like they can
they're gonna be talking spreading
fake rumors i can't trust those
champions you literally can't trust a
gorilla and they like
no sign language they're capable of
learning sign language and they can like
lie to you in sign language it is so
scary and so just for my own personal
like fear-based answer i want to be able
to control them
so that they're not so terrifying
because even at the zoo i'm like
i don't trust this
i don't trust this i'm not going to lean
over the edge i'm not going gonna throw
food in there i don't like it they
they're too much they're basically as
smart as us but ten times as strong and
i don't like it oh yes oh man have you
seen the newer planet of the apes movies
yeah
literally it's they could literally take
over the planet
[Music]
i'm smart
freaking animals
and then you would be the marina master
of the
[Music]
that's actually a very smart answer
because like they're basically like
junior humans essentially um that will
sorry so scary
um what would i choose i would probably
choose something really stupid
um you know what i think i'm gonna say
dogs even though it's just a really oh
my god you could control everybody's pet
exactly i would tell all the dogs to
turn against their owners
exactly this is how the avengers come to
fight me this is how i become the super
villain but yo you could like take over
countries that way because everybody has
a pet and you could like like any world
leader like uh biden has a a dog a
couple of dogs dude
it's like secret invasion for dogs
secret invasion bark edition
you can like
seriously do some damage like
controlling everybody's dog just because
everybody trusts their dog too
exactly man's best friend until someone
comes and controls them wow
i think we're making a movie right now i
think this is what's happening
i would watch that wow i just realized
how vulnerable we all are we keep
trusting those guys they're licking
their but like they're licking
their maliciously yeah you
never know they're planning they're
playing give us all pink eye
that's the true plot that's the end game
well that is it for this episode of big
question thank you of course to marina
mastros for joining us you can follow
her on twitter at marina mastros and you
can of course follow me at
mastertainment on twitter tweet a lot of
weird subscribe to do rockstars
wherever we are especially on youtube
and when you do please hit that bell so
you can get notifications whenever we
upload a video which is fairly
constantly because we love you and we
can't stop we have a problem uh just
kidding all right thank you guys for so
much for watching and we'll see you
later goodbye
[Music]
you